hi everyone this is my first time here
in Oslo so thank you for coming and
before we begin let me see a raise of
hands how many of you have heard about
it when sourcing and secure raise before
wow that's a nice girlfriend well keep
your hands up please how many of you
have implemented a system using these
patterns cool so I hope I will teach you
something new today my name is Li dun
and I lead the user notifications
platform team eight weeks a long time
ago
I think it was 2010 I consulted to a
startup that wanted to organize the
photos that people upload it to Facebook
and the idea was to aggregate all the
photos that were taken at the same
location or at the same event so that
people can discover them easily on the
social network now remember it was 2010
there was no Instagram or snapchat one
of the hardest buzz words those days was
social network everyone did it at least
they thought they did and we also try to
build a social graph on top of those
photos that connects people locations
events and in photos so we started to
build a network we used my sequel as
database we had a table for locations
and a table for photos and events and a
table of relationships that connects
them all so I asked them guys how are
you going to create the table in large
scale and they were like we don't know
yet but don't worry I left a couple of
friends later and when they started to
grow they spent thousands of dollars to
maintain this unusable super expensive
structure instead of using a better
structure for this use case like a graph
database in the long run they didn't
survive but this story is an excellent
example of accidental complexity we
model our data in some way and when the
requirements change and the model
doesn't fit anymore we work very hard to
maintain it instead of using the better
structure that is more suitable for the
new requirement
and there all kinds of models can cause
us a ridiculous amount of accidental
complexity and today I'm gonna talk
about this problem and I'll show you how
event sourcing and CQRS can help you
solve it a few years later I joined wigs
as a back-end developer in the crm
platform team and which is an Israeli
company that offers web site builder
that allows you to create stunning
websites effortlessly you just drag and
drop elements to a site like building a
PowerPoint presentation and we also
offer more than 300 applications that
everyone can add to the website week's
build some of them and you can see some
examples here and there are also
third-party applications in the crm
platform team we build tools for SMBs
small medium businesses that help them
to grow and manage their businesses
online such as contacts chat and
invoices and when I join when I joined
the team it was the early days of the
english's project and the idea was
simple the business owner goes to the
app issues a new invoice and sends it to
the customer the customer receives that
invoice and pays it online for example
via PayPal the business owner can always
manage the in recess and track what was
already paid what hasn't been paid yet
and see the overdue invoices now we're
all developers right so given some
mock-ups we know more or less 90% of the
work okay I don't need the project
manager to say the save button should
save the invoice in the database so we
started to design the solution it's a
classical layered architecture there is
a rest endpoint that handles requests
that is data coming from the client
passes it to the business logic that
does some magic and save it in the
database through a domain model so the
user creates an invoice
he fills in the form clicks on the Save
button and then we make a post request
to the server we think really really
hard what to do we make a decision and
we start the decision in the database
this is how a new invoice is saved after
some time the user realized he had made
a mistake so he goes to the invoice he
edits the details and click on save
again we think really really hard what
to do we find the relevant record in the
database and change it in place
according to the users request and you
probably noticed that when the system is
designed like this we lose data by
design ok it's not a security issue or a
technical constraint this is how the
system is designed and well this
architecture might be perfect for some
applications mostly because of its
simplicity it cannot be used by
financial applications why regulation
for weeks and also for excuses by law we
have to give our users the ability to
track every action that was done in
their invoices another requirement was
scalability Wix is more than 120 million
users and 5 billion requests a day ok
and every invoice is viewed by the users
of our users so we are talking about
large numbers and doing it right is
challenging obviously we can add more
and more servers but it has a cost and
of course as a leading company in the
web industry we want to be flexible and
be able to add new features quickly and
easily so we thought about new ways to
design the system to satisfy these
requirements and we started researching
best practices in in different
industries there is one industry that is
prominent in regulation and scale can
someone guess what it is
does anyone here think that when he or
she withdraws money from an ATM the
record in the database changes and
what's interesting for me is that it's
not only the banking industry the
tubeless approach every single mature
industry that you look at is naturally
event sourced financial medical
insurance legal all of them are
conceptually event sourced and that's
what naturally brought us start looking
at event sourcing for our invoice
management application event sourcing is
a way to model your data that doesn't
store the current state but rather a
sequence of events that led us to this
state starting from some initial state
and we can always restore the current
state by replaying the events and derive
it from them of course we cannot do it
oppositely in this approach every action
in our system is expressed by either
domain language and we have two basic
building blocks we have commands and
events a command is an external request
that is coming to our system it is
always expressed in imperative language
like creating voice daleney invoice it
represents users intent to do something
in our system and it may have a payload
with some relevant details notice how
meaningful the command is compared to
HTTP language like creating voice versus
post slash invoice etc etc after
validating the command it is transformed
into a chain of events it can be one
event or more that represents facts
something that happened in our system
and why the command the event may also
have a payload with some relevant
details and the event name is always in
in past form like create invoice in was
created the leading voice it was deleted
okay
and events are immutable they'll never
change so let's say you are a business
owner you created an invoice and you
made a mistake now you want to delete
this invoice so what do you do you issue
a command of deleting with command and
this command is transformed to in which
deleted event but entry section was not
removed from the system just mark is
deleted it's it's a logical delete we
are stating actions taken from the
language of the business domain these
are not SQL statements like insert or
select and not functions in your favor
right Aurum the language is universal
among everyone involved whether a
developer or domain expert read the
sequence they will get a full story and
they will easily understand it after
transforming the command to events we
store the events in the database with
the fast insert operation and the events
are the single source of truth of the
system as you can see the database
doesn't hold the current state rather it
holds the sequence of events that led us
to this state and the benefit the
benefit here is there instead of writing
down our decision we are writing down
what the user wanted from us when user
wants to view an invoice it's also
called the current state referred to as
an aggregate in ddd domain driven design
we retrieve the events of that invoice
from the database and we apply them one
by one and rebuild the finalized state
that is eventually returned to the user
and for those of you who are familiar
with functional programming concepts
you can think about the state is the
left fold or the previous behaviors in
each iteration the event changes the
current state of the early date and
after iterating all the past events we
return the state to the user so now when
we store every single action and we are
able to rebuild the current state from
those actions our system is regulatory
compliant but more importantly we are
not losing data and the whole system is
described by the domain language and not
in the language that technology forced
us to use but now we have a problem if
we only store events how do you query
them well I have an idea
let's replay every vent that was ever
stored in the system
you should be fast right so let's talk
about queries and more importantly
querying it scale if we examine the
distribution of flow between read and
write operations in in web-scale
application most systems have more read
operations that deny their operations it
actually mutate the data more or less
it's around 90% of them are read
operations and when we design a system
in large scale we tend to bind the read
and the write model despite the fact
that in most cases they are totally
different it is much easier to scale
riddle quest of immutable data than
write requests we don't need to manage
complex locking mechanisms or handle
inconsistencies and besides that most of
the time we don't want to read the data
in the same form it was written in okay
how many of you have large complex SQL
statements like these in your
application come on don't be shy we all
have it I just look at me squaring and
the only thought that comes to my mind
is what the hell is going on here
so crowd is difficult to scare but with
we have more considerations like
normalizing the data to support new
features in the future I'm like
full-text search or graphic capabilities
they are not supported by the current
data store
you remember my story from the beginning
so in fact what we need to do is to
separate the process of updates and the
provision of queries and this pattern is
called CQRS
ok stands for command query
responsibility segregation in most of
the events or systems usually don't
query your events you end up with a
concept called rid models or views so
every time a new event is written to the
system it may also update a view and a
view is read optimized set a set of data
that is used to make the reads faster it
can be normalized pre aggregated table
in my sequel but it doesn't have to be
relational actually we can here you can
use a JSON file elasticsearch schema and
it's not necessarily stored in the same
day store like the events okay you can
use different data stores for different
kinds of view and this pattern allows
allows us to see our data from different
points of view when in your requirement
comes we just add a new view to the
system and build it by replaying the
events from the beginning so when you
work this way you cannot change what
happened in the past but you can have a
new perception of what happened in the
past and I'll give you an example this
is a screenshot from our invoice
management application and you have the
numbers on the top you have paid sent an
average you and actually it is stored in
the database in the same form you can
see it here in
in the user interface we have the same
columns we have page sent in a video and
of course another column that identifies
the the tenant and also for the table
below the table of the invoices we have
the same table in my sink well we have
another come for the tenant a identifier
so it looks simple but if you introduce
you new ways to design and architect
your systems for example you can you can
execute the read and the write model in
the same service or separate them to
different services and different
databases and when you have two separate
services you can scale each of them
independently okay you can deploy the
right model in your own data center and
move the rig model to the cloud but when
using this pattern and separating the
the models you should take in account
the inconsistency window between writing
the events to the event store and
updating the views accordingly and you
lose the strong consistency and you end
up with eventual consistency and while
some applications can live with that
limitation others cannot so it depends
on the business prominence one more
thing about CTRs is there you can use
secure res pattern without event
sourcing although then naturally go
together and I'll give you an example
when you publish a Wix website we create
a special special site that is highly
optimized for our for our viewer
application and it is stored separately
from the is the editing model we have
the editing model and the viewer model
and it allows you it allows we close us
sorry two separate weeks to two
different segments we have the arrow
segment and we have the public
segments and each segment has its own
scaling policy and SLA policy so you can
use securest
without event source engine that's
totally fine remember that CQRS is an
optimization and like every optimization
be aware of doing it prematurely it is
difficult to do it well and it makes the
system more complex so please don't try
to solve problems that are probably not
existent in the system okay and out of
everything I will say today this one is
probably the most important I would
suggest you consider doing CPRS when you
really have scaling issues in the system
and when the distribution of flow
between read and write operations is
highly as symmetrical for example in the
image management application we started
by reading the events in every reader
quest and building the views in memory
and when the applications grow in
scalability started to be an issue we
changed some views to be persistent and
that improved the response time of the
read model so eventually we came up with
the following design so when a user
wants to send an invoice to his customer
and the clients issues a command and
send in with the customer and then it
makes a post request to execute endpoint
and then we pass this command to the
command decoder the command decoder is
responsible for the this realization
from JSON object to JVM object so we can
do some validations and we will touch
the validation soon and then it is
passed to the command Handler and the
command handler is responsible for
transforming the command to
events can be event or sequence of
events and then we first store the event
to the event store and then we publish
it to the event bus and we have multiple
consumers of that bus
we have analytics for BI and we have
emails
it is consumers that actually sends the
invoice to the customer and we have read
optimize view for example the table the
table of invoices I showed you earlier
we just update the status of the invoice
from draft to send so this is the the
right flow obviously it's very high
level and the red flow is very very
simple when you work is why we just go
to the end point invoice with invoice ID
and then we just go to the read optimize
view we fetch the relevant view and
return to the user we have another arrow
we will touch it soon and that updates
the view during the read process we just
compare the version from the event store
in the view and if there is a gap we
update the view and return it it's like
a self-healing mechanism so now by using
the secure arrest pattern the system can
run in large scale and we can add new
features easily by creating views but
basically we got more than that first
since we store every user's action
without an audit log for free and by
design every change in our system is
logged in accurately and because we are
relying on it as a source of truth we
are more confident to use it than a
regular text file that's actually a very
powerful tool you can use this log for
different purposes for example for
testing purposes
if you want to understand what led the
user to the current state like a
debugging tool so you can also use this
audit log you can also take those events
and replay them in different environment
in different datastore isolated from the
production environment if let's say we
want to test a new feature and want to
test it on on the existing data we can
just take this feature isolated from the
production environment and replay the
events with a new feature actually we
can restore the system at some point in
time by replaying the events until that
point so if you want to know how an
aggregate looks like a few weeks ago you
can just do it and you cannot only
restore the data but you can analyze
historical data that would be lost if
you didn't use event sourcing as our
data model for example when you whenever
you come up with a new idea or new
algorithm to analyze your data you can
just update the event handler and then
replay the events from the beginning and
this is a very powerful tool and trust
me you're bi analysts will thank you for
that another interesting feature is the
ability to create different schemas
according to the system requirements and
the event stream is the single source of
truth of the system and views are
derived from it
think about it at any point in time I
can blow away my views completely and
rebuild them from the events this
ability makes it easier for everyone in
your company to consume that event
stream and build their own view of the
world so I'm looking at you and you
probably think
silver bullets right too good to be true
so I'm going to tell you a secret event
sourcing in CTRs are not magical
solutions for your system as you
probably know choices of architecture
are never good versus bad it's just a
trade-off it's some context and you must
take into account the complexities of
every solution you choose ok it's not
necessarily relevant to events often
CQRS it's relevant for every
architecture in every system you build
some challenges are raised only when you
work on on a real application with real
traffic and real business behind it and
those challenges can appear in two
different forms number one the
development model is unusual especially
when you work with separated read and
write models it feels strange at the
beginning there is learning curve but
it's not that hard to get you straight
but let me ask you a question
why do you prefer a very thin layer that
handles commands and events or a very
complex database schema that restricts
the courage you can run now after
separating the read and the write models
you can work with different data stores
for various models well how do you
manage them how do you do backups
what about monitoring so during the
development of weeks invoices and some
other risk products that used our event
sourcing infrastructure to manage their
data we encountered three major
challenges
how do you keep your views in a
consistent state is your application has
to be fully consistent or can it be
settled for eventually consistent
eventual consistency means the data
doesn't have to be consistent all the
time
the only guarantee is that data becomes
consistent at some point in time
eventually and for most applications
eventual eventual consistency is
sufficient but there is no single
solution for that again it is always a
trade-off between consistency and
performance okay it's it's based on the
business and the domain requirements so
first of all we can build a fully
consistent system by replaying the
events in every read request and
building the views in memory the
disadvantage of this approach is the
strong binding between the read and the
write model which makes it harder to
scale a system especially when you work
with complex views another possible
solution is to use is to do CQRS with
sync synchronous writes I don't have to
use a heavy weight distributed bus like
Kafka in order to update your views you
can just do it synchronously in this
approach we have all the benefits of the
normalized read optimized views but the
writes will be slower since we need to
update multiple views so we can do it
better and a better solution might be
comparing the current version of the
view with the current version of the
event store and if there is a gap
between them we update the view and
return it to the user so these are the
main three solutions of handling views
inconsistency and of course
it is suitable you can choose the
consistency level per view and you can
also mix these methods it depends on on
a view consistency is a product concern
not technology and this is a very
important point and most of the team
don't do this conversation with a
product manager they just choose the
consistency level by themselves so I'm
really sorry guys but it's not our
business just give it to give the
product manager to decide and do it so
the next topic is validation how do you
validate the commands in your system and
validations come in different variations
we have a different level of validations
and the basic level of validation is
validating the payload data for example
string length or numbers range and in
weeks
we use a code for this kind of
validation accord is an open source car
based library that allows you to
validate input data easily and with a
very very simple DSL and you can see an
example here even if you don't know
skaara the syntax is very simple and
this is the first stage of the
validation process we can also verify
that a given command can be performed on
the current state of some domain entity
for example the application cannot
handle update command if the aggregate
was already deleted and for this use
case we mark these special commands
delete create we start rate scarlet rate
is like a Java interface and when we
handle the
we take its type against the current
state of the aggregate and what about
more complex validations for instance
let's talk about uniqueness imagine that
you are developing a contact management
system okay
how can you make sure that there is only
one contact pertinent with given email
so a possible solution for this case is
creating a special persistent view for
for this validation that contains all
the emails that belong to some tenant
and on the validation phase before
transforming the command to events we
check if the given email already exists
and if it does we'll throw an exception
and I know I know some of you may
probably notice that validation that is
based on a view may raise inconsistency
problems and you're basically right
again it depends on the business and the
domain requirement some systems can live
with this invalid data once I don't know
in once in a million rights but are the
others cannot and you should take in
account when you design a system using
secure risks and eventually the last
thing I want to talk about is concurrent
rights so let's see all the two commands
were written at the same time updating
voice and leading voice what would be
the state of this invoice eventually so
one solution is pessimistic locking so
only one command pool aggregate can be
handled at the same time once the first
command takes the lock any other command
will wait for that for the lock to be
released and this is the safest way to
prevent concurrency issues but obviously
it's
the slowest and most complex way we need
to manage distributed lock and handle
timeouts yak so we have a much better
solution so let's talk about optimistic
locking or versioning so each event or
the aggregate has a version it's it is
incremented by one every time a new
event is written to the system the
version of the r8 is the version of its
last event and in this solution each
command has the expected version it is
the version that the aggregate was when
the command was issued and in case of a
gap between the expected version and the
current version will throw an exception
we can also resolve the conflict by
merging the events if if possible and
let's see an example so here we have two
different events that written at the
same time with the same version but
different type in this use case we can
merge the event by incrementing one of
the events by one but in this case we
have two different events with the same
type with the same version and they were
written at the same time so we cannot
resolve it and in this use case
we'll throw an exception and you can
guess that also here the way we handle
concurrent writes is based on the
business requirements not on the
technology in a content management
system we can probably merge events have
the address event and new email event so
that's fine however if we Spanish meant
in
mounting a more sensitive domains and
merging the events may change the
English completely so we've talked about
CQRS event sourcing and we've seen how
to design a system using them and some
challenges that you're going to face so
whatever we learnt weeks in the past
three years from using these patterns
first of all start small
don't try to model every entity in your
system using events that's a real bad
idea so before you go back and say we
done say it we should separate read and
write and model every entity in our
system with events ask yourself the
following question they all really have
a benefit by storing the history of
those actions is it worth the
operational cost of modeling it with
events or can you remain with quad I'll
give you an example in in the in waste
management application we have a feature
called tax presets it's a taxes name and
tax rate and it's a preset just you can
use it to create invoices faster is this
feature worth the cost of modeling with
events what would if you look like tax
name tax rate and tenant ID so grant
sounds like a better better approach
here although the rest of the system is
all events source code changes once an
event of some type was written to the
datastore you cannot remove its
definition from the codebase it is
always it's also harder to make changes
in the event like adding fields or
removing fields you should always think
about backwards compatibility
and remember once events are written to
the datastore there will be there
forever okay so your your code should
know how to handle them and even when
you stop writing them or deprecated the
events so either do a migration plan to
migrate the old events to new events or
just make your code to handle the old
events the last and the most important
point in my opinion is that events are
the fundamental source of truth and you
can always delete the views and
reconstruct them by replaying the events
this ability gives you a lot of power
you can build your user interface
incrementally you don't have to
normalize your data right complex
queries or run data migration scripts
just remove the view and build a new one
from the events so I hope I convinced
you that it's worth researching more
here are some references that might be
helpful for you and here are some JVM
libraries that allows you to build event
sourcing and CQRS applications we are
working on open sourcing our internal
event sourcing library hopefully we will
release it soon
now also similar similar libraries in
the JavaScript world in dotnet and
that's the whole idea okay
it's a pattern it's patterns are
language agnostic okay
language is implementation detail but
people are always asking me okay that's
a very nice pattern but we want to see
some code give us some
for example some so let's see how we
implemented the event rippling mechanism
in in Scala if you have any questions
about the syntax just raise your hand so
here we have the load method we have the
tenant ID and the aggregate ID and we
can pass a revision if you want to view
an aggregate in specific version it is
optional and the first step we just
fetch the events from the event store we
have the event stream reader that just
read the events from the database and
then we build the aggregate we have the
reduce function that is passed to the
class not to the metal and we have the
empty state the empty state is based on
the algorithm okay a and we just map the
events to to the data just need the
payload and then after building the
aggregate we return the snapshot to the
user but this is this is an important
line so let's see how implement the
reducer we have a user we have the
reduce method it depends on the
aggregate so every aggregate implements
its own reduce function and we have the
aggregate and events and the method
returns a new aggregate and we have the
apply method that just fold left with a
some initial state and with a reduced
function and this is looks familiar
no we have the reduce do remember this
slide from the beginning
so they summarized event sourcing is a
pattern that allows you to capture your
users intent by writing down the house
story of what the user does in your
system this pattern goes naturally with
another pattern CQRS that gives you the
power to evolve your business logic
incrementally by using views and by
separating the read operations in the
write operations it allows you to
resolve scaling issues that may be
raised when a system grow
however like every other architecture
there are some trade-offs that you must
take in account when working this way
and we've talked about them we talked
we've talked about validations we've
talked about handling views
inconsistencies and how to handle
concurrent rights so in conclusion if we
go back when we started the inversus
project none of us had an idea of what
events or single secure arrests are we
knew the concepts but we had no idea how
to implement them and what are the
challenges were going to face since then
we've migrated and implemented multiples
products in you in weeks to use our
event sourcing infrastructure to manage
the data it absolutely changed the way I
think about data thank you very much
keep it in your event store
so before you before you I we moved
their questions I'd like to hear what
you thought about a presentation and if
you have any feedback so if you'd like
the slide just go to this URL now yes
secure is there online
answer a very short survey it was like
use 30 seconds and promise 30 seconds
push submit and you'll be taken to the
slide and I'm also available in Twitter
if you have any questions so feel free
to contact me and I'll be here for
questions and I have some quick spin so
feel free to take some and enjoy the
party tonight thank you
[Applause]